leere Autobahn leere Straßen kein
einziges Auto zumindest an einem Tag pro
Woche ein autofreier Tag was soll das
Fragen
offenbar Millionen von Menschen aber für
einen ist das völlig okay und zwar
Markus düßmann ja ausgerechnet für
diesen machen nämlich für den Audi Boss
das ist schon eine verrückte Geschichte
er sagt jetzt in einem Gespräch mit der
Süddeutschen Zeitung ja ja ganz genau um
uns in Deutschland besser einzustimmen
auf die Lage und die Notwendigkeit des
Sparens könnte es wieder autofreie Tage
in Deutschland geben genauso wie in den
70er Jahren also der Audi Chef der hier
für ein autofreien Tag wirkt das ist
schon irre oder Auto bildchef Tom
Drechsler verrückt ja das erstmal
verrückt weil es so paradox klingt der
will doch Autos verkaufen aber dazu muss
er das auch Wissen der verkauft im
200.000 Autos in Deutschland also
eigentlich 180.000 letztes Jahr und 1,4
Millionen Autos ganz woanders deswegen
ist sie in Deutschland vielleicht gar
nicht mehr so wichtig oh das ist aber
eine schlechte Nachricht das ist schon
wurscht ob hier noch auf den Straßen
fahren das ist Erklärung und die das
letzte autofreie Sonntag der letzte war
1973 das ist lange her da gab es 20
Millionen weniger Autos als heute ich
sag mal wenn Markus düssmann hat gesagt
er möchte mit dem Rennrad dann über die
Autobahn fahren über wäre Autobahn wenn
ich mit dem mit meiner Family mit den
Fahrrädern über die Autobahn fahre um
300 Kilometer weit zu fahren um Oma und
Opa zu besuchen fände ich jetzt nicht so
richtig charmant am Sonntag weil da
Sonntag ist aber du nicht ja wir kommen
alle an nur ein Tag später
ja man muss aber wissen natürlich spart
das was also es gibt ja für alles eine
Rechnung in Deutschland das hat man auch
mal ausgerechnet also zwei autofreie
Sonntage pro Monat das sind aber dann 24
im Jahr wenn ich jetzt richtig rechne ja
sind es sparen 1,3 Millionen Tonnen
Kraftstoff ihr müsst wissen wir
verkaufen in Deutschland eine irre Zahl
über 100 Millionen Liter Diesel am Tag
am Tag 100 Millionen musste zweimal
nachgucken ob die Zahl überhaupt stimmt
stimmt aber und natürlich kann man
sparen wenn man weniger fährt aber der
letzte Versuch ist lange lange her und
ich habe eine anderes andere Idee was
das mot öffnen könnte
man spart natürlich als OEM also als
Hersteller und Audi ist jetzt der erste
der das mal sagt Audi sind auch die die
den letzten Verbrenner 26 auf die Straße
schieben der dann noch bis 33 fährt
danach bauen sie Verbrenner und noch in
China aber nicht mehr hier
das spart wenn du Autos nicht mehr
entwickeln musst die so 220 fahren
sondern nur noch 140 150 160 und wir
denken eh Autos haben automatisches
Tempolimit eingebaut die meisten
jedenfalls damit kannst du mal schnell
fahren ein ampelsport gewinnen aber an
der Autobahn macht viel mehr Spaß wenn
130 140 fährst dann kommst Du nämlich
auch da an wo du hin willst mit dem Akku
das spart in Entwicklung das könnte eine
Einleitung sein dass Audi auch sieht wie
kann man Geld dann Entwicklung sparen
also er will gar nicht dass wir sparen
sondern er will vor allen Dingen am Ende
selber sparen
hochspannende Geschichte danke für den
Besuch bei uns danke an Auto bildchef
Tom Drechsler zu diesem ja wie ich finde
weiter irrenplan Ausgänge der Audi Auto
Boss sagt autofreier Sonntag völlig okay
für uns
[Musik]